10h ce matin les portes du lycée
marie-curie s'ouvrent les lycées en se
précipitent à l'intérieur du bâtiment
une dernière épreuve les attend avant le
soulagement trouvé leur nom dans ses
longues listes pour savoir s'ils ont
obtenu leur baccalauréat en quelques
minutes
l'anxiété et le stress d'ici et laisse
place aux cris de joie et fusion et
larmes
là
c'est quoi ta meilleure note
genevois
c'est bien ou mal
c'est pas sûr
ben ouais ça fait toujours une grande
joie
même si l'élève
fillon
balcons
à peine remis de leurs émotions les
bacheliers vont chercher leurs dossiers
dans les files d'attentes les lycéens
trépigne d'impatience après une
signature
ils peuvent enfin découvrir les notes
qu'ils ont obtenu les rires s'envole
dans la salle les feuilles de notes
s'échangent entre amis pas peu fier
toussaint pas de sauver
ils s'étaient tous
une fierté partagée par les professeurs
résultat à la main les diplômés se
précipite vers ceux qui les ont
accompagnés toute l'année pour leur
annoncer la bonne nouvelle
sa fierté
on se rappelle cette époque là aussi
c'était pas si loin
forcément
après cette date c'est pour le
petit côté statistiques voir si c'est à
peu près cohérent et l'avenir
l'an dernier le département avait obtenu
88,8 % de réussite au baccalauréat un
résultat au dessus de la moyenne
nationale mais il faudra attendre
vendredi et la fin des épreuves de
rattrapage pour savoir si les yvelines
enregistre cette année encore un bon
résultat